Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Irgendwie gibt's gerade nichts über das man sich ordentlich lächerlich machen kann.
Wir können es ja mal mit einem lustigen hass gesetz versuchen.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertzweiunddreißig vom wunderschönen einundzwanzigsten februar zweitausendundzwanzig linus.
Das wird bestimmt eine total unterhaltsame sendung heute.
Ach wir kloppen einfach ein paar hanauer.
Hallo.
Neues aus hanau.
Wir machen wir machen einfach mal feedback.
Fängt gut an.
Zur letzten sendung gab es sehr schönes und sehr viel feedback.
Zur vorletzten und zuletzt also ja zu allen aber ich beziehe mich jetzt primär erstmal auf die vorletzte wo ich ja noch mit dabei war.
Und zwar hatten ich lese einfach mal so ein bisschen vor kartoffel marmelade hat kommentiert,
indimedia und alter media sind meiner ansicht nach nicht vergleichbar meines wissens und der wikipedia artikel bestätigt das hatte alter media eine redaktion die artikel verfasste und aus anderen quellen,
übernahm es gab also eine gruppe.
Die artikel verfasste die gemeinschaftlich handelte und für alle artikel verantwortlich war aus meiner erinnerung und dem überfliegen einiger zeitungsartikel aus der zeit gewinne ich den eindruck dass die artikel auf alter media mehrheitlich strafrechtlich relevant waren.
Indem wir die links unten hingegen hatte erstmal alle artikel übernommen und veröffentlichte ihn zugeschickt wurden ohne überprüfung also zugeschickt open posting muss ja noch nicht mal zugeschickt sondern konnte es einfach veröffentlichen eine moderation fand im nachhinein statt
es gab einige artikel die scheinbar von den betreiberinnen stammten aber die waren wieder strafrechtlich relevant strafrechtlich nicht relevant soweit ich weiß die betreiberin wurden nie.
Mit zufriedenstellender gewissheit identifiziert es wird sich auf ominöse geheimdienst kenntnisse berufen,
zudem war nur ein geringer teil der artikel strafrechtlich relevant ich bin der meinung dass das vereinsvertreter konstrukt auch im falle von alter media bestenfalls fragwürdig war.
Aber wenigstens wurde dem betreibenden in diesem fall ihre betreiberin schafft vorher nachgewiesen.
Sie hätten die vorangegangenen verurteilen wegen volksverhetzung das verwenden von kennzeichen verfassungswidriger organisationen und aufrufe zu straftaten anfechten können sie hätten das vereinsvertreter anfechten können,
ohne sich weiter zu gefährden sehr gut zusammengefasst die unterschiede und gemeinsamkeiten zwischen den beiden fällen vielen dank.
Das zeigt zumindest dass es dann wirklich nicht so ohne weiteres vergleichbar ist insofern sehr hilfreicher kommentar das hätten wir uns auch einfacher machen können.
Genau richtig dann punkt.
Hat kommentiert hallo danke ein weiteres mal für gute einordnung zu allen themen kurze ergänzung zur hufeisentheorie diese besagt nicht nur.
Das rechts und links genau gleich schlimm sein.
Schlimm ist eher ein unpräzise begriff sondern sie besagt primär dass links und rechts ihre radikalisierung gegenseitig auslöse.
Lösen und nur die marinierte mitte sei in der lage diesen extremen lagern gegensteuert zu geben
eigentlich ist die hufeisentheorie oft ausdruck einer radikalisierten mitte im gegenteil wenn man es geschichtlich betrachtet konnte sich der faschismus immer nur dann durchsetzen wenn die mitte sich nicht mehr dagegen gesperrt hat
darum wurde die fischhaut theorie entworfen die besagt dass die menschenverachtende radikalisierung der rechten.
Durch die mitte gespielt wird illustriert eben mit einem fischerhafen der sich in der mitte hin zurück biegt.
Genau dies wurde ja in thüringen bestens illustriert.
Auch dafür vielen dank weil so genau so gut hätte ich das nicht erklären können und war mir glaube ich auch wahrscheinlich deswegen nicht so klar.
Das ist auch eine interessante these heißt ja im prinzip auch dass man.
Louis am rand sehr wohl ertragen kann und keinen anlass gibt ihn gleich hinterher zu rennen weil genau dadurch dass man das tut fördert man sozusagen ihre agenda.
Kommen wir heute im laufe der sendung sicherlich auch nochmal drauf zurück herbert hat kommentiert,
den kommentar habe ich etwas abgekürzt dazu möchte ich ihnen amazon fall vor circa elf jahren erinnern der mir dazu einfällt die hatten damals ein problem mit buche lizenzen und haben dann von den geräten der kunden rückwirkend die illegal verkauften bücher wieder gelöscht das stimmt.
Und das buch.
Auf was jetzt.
Vor.
Auf was bezieht sich das jetzt.
Achso der bezieht sich auf diese ganze frage mit wenn dein produkt,
irgendwie in software abgebildet ist und es per fernwartung dem kunden wieder weggenommen werden kann und herbert bezieht sich auf den fall ich weiß nicht ob's vor elf jahren war oder vor vor neun oder vor zehn wie auch immer.
Da wurde hat jemand quasi vor als e-book verkauft an amazon kunden.
Und es hatte aber nicht wirklich die lizenzen hatte quasi einfach eingestellt und hier den etv für kinder so ja und er hat sich irgendwann rausgestellt dass das.
Eben nicht okay war so dass sie nicht die rechte hatte dieses buch zu verkaufen und dann hat amazon quasi von seinen kunden,
vor einfach wieder remote gelöscht vom kindl.
Was natürlich blöd ist weil du also nein vor beispielsweise eben ein buch ist was viel in schulen gelesen wird
jetzt weiß ich natürlich nicht ob es irgendwo auf der welt schon so eine moderne schule gibt dass die kind mal mit dem kinder lesen könnte aber natürlich auch notizen amputation und sonstiges waren dann halt wieder gelöscht.
Genau also sowieso sehr viele parallelen zu diesem ganzen also zu solchen digitalen erwerb weil ja zum beispiel auch das digitale erbe irgendwie eine.
Ein thema ist was noch nicht so ganz geklärt ist ne also weil kannst du deine drei sammlung vererben oder nicht.
Oder hat eben haben die anderen wenn sie die in den fingern haben nicht die die die rechte an diesen an diesen und ähnlich geht natürlich dann auch weiter mit zugängen in social networks und sonstigen scherzen.
Oder auch nicht nur vererben sondern auch
verschenken aber mir fällt jetzt gerade so gesagt hast kann man das vererben können wir gleich wieder ein so oh ja erbschaft recht unser großes problem also großteil des des vermögens der herrschenden klasse wird quasi durch,
durch erbe weitergereicht und es gibt einfach viele leute die nie einen finger haben regen müssen um irgendwie sehr viel geld und damit sehr viel einfluss zu haben
und das ist halt auch so ein bisschen die grundlage
unserer ungerechtigkeit nicht die einzige aber auf jeden fall ein wichtiger teil davon so und natürlich wenn man so ein bisschen vorsorge auch haben für die kinder finde ich auch angemessen.
Aber genauso könnte man ja auch sagen,
warum kann ich auch nicht das was ich digital gekauft habe auch verschenken also kann ich etwas was digital gekauft habe jemand anderem schenken und dann geht es sozusagen in seinen lizenz besitz über geht halt auch derzeit nicht.
Mit einer cd machen kann.
Könnte könnte amazon aber zum beispiel natürlich auch dann unter ihrem dm regime trotzdem ermöglichen.
Durchaus denkbar und nicht nur amazon.
So dann ein kommentar von wikileaks historiker erstens wikileaks hat von anfang an nicht nur daten veröffentlicht,
sondern die auch redaktionell eingeordnet erklärt kontext geliefert nur ein beispiel von zweitausendacht das war das so,
der vicky teil des namens war ja auch die idee gemeinsam einzuordnen und zu berichten ja kann man jetzt sehen wie viel da so eingeordnet und berichtet wurde ich meinte mit der redaktionellen aufarbeitung natürlich auch irgendwie sachen,
löschen,
sachen nach und nach veröffentlichen und mit sicherheit waren die log und was es da alles gab,
die wurden halt von den anderen medienhäusern sicherlich sehr viel mehr aufgearbeitet in einem rahmen der journalistisch,
genannt werden kann als jetzt irgendwie mal ein dokument was wikileaks mal von von big veröffentlicht hat.
Ja und ganz am anfang war das war das auch nicht unbedingt so also das.
Es war nicht open posting das stimmt schon.
Also am anfang gab es auch sagen wir mal diese mentalität in dem projekt noch nicht so in dem maße sondern da war das halt auch im wesentlichen so na ja gott euer problem so das hat sich dann,
zwar am anfang aber auch eben erst dann entwickelt und durchgesetzt journalistische gedanke.
Ein wichtiger punkt den wir die letzten sendungen also den wir in den früheren sendungen sehr viel mehr betont haben.
Sagt der wikileaks historiker zweitens associates begründung,
warum er nicht nach schweden wollte war dass die ihn an die usa ausliefern das war nie unwahrscheinlich
er hat das aber gesagt als er war und dass die ihn jetzt nicht nur theoretisch ausliefern könnten sondern auch praktisch tun beweist sich ja jetzt ungereimtheiten hin oder her damit gibt es keinen nachvollziehbaren grund
schweden nicht zu stellen stattdessen kamen antifeministische tierarten wie schweden ist das saudi-arabien des feminismus ja das.
Ich würde ja fast sagen dass die das ergebnis oder des.
Die auslieferung an die usa kann ja immer nur dann passieren wenn es ein auslieferungs besuch gibt und,
das auslieferungs gesucht gab es diese gesamte zeit über nicht.
Diese gesamte zeit über damit meine ich insbesondere die zeit die ihr in der ecuadorianischen botschaft saß und.
Das erscheint mir wenn man sich jetzt hier mal so den lauf der dinge anschaut dann doch eben,
ziemlich genau absichtlich so gewesen zu sein also seine wenn wir jetzt mal blicken auf die sieben jahre,
in der ecuadorianischen botschaft mit einem schwebenden nicht abgeschlossenen irgendwie komischen verfahren in schweden wegen sexueller,
straftaten
das kam irgendwie alles zu einem sehr zügigen ende als er auf einmal aus dieser botschaft raus war und es scheint schon so zu sein dass es eben eine ein strategischer schritt war zu sagen alles klar solange der sich uns entzieht durch seinen aufenthalt in der ecuadorianischen botschaft,
halten wir einfach dieses damoklesschwert über ihn weil wir wissen dass jeder der mal über ihn bericht,
egal welchem zusammenhang immer sagen muss versteckt sich in der ecuadorianischen botschaft
um ein ermittlungsverfahren gegen wegen,
sexueller straftaten in schweden zu entgehen und das ist natürlich etwas wenn du jemanden so so einem vorwurf sieben jahre lang aussetzt und dass sich daran etwas ändert dann passiert das in der regel nicht ohne absicht.
Drittens die ausführungen über die motive der frauen sind interessant,
aber auch nur ein weiteres mensch was die frauen eigentlich wollen interessanter wäre was sie selbst dazu öffentlich sagen und das haben sie jetzt,
haben sie ihren vorwürfen nie widersprochen da bin ich mir noch nicht mal so sicher wir sind sehr selten in erscheinung getreten und ich muss sich natürlich auch vorstellen,
das waren ja irgendwelche privatpersonen und wenn die auf einmal im interesse der weltöffentlichkeit stehen,
und erfahrungen machen müssen mit dieser form von öffentlichkeit arbeit wirklichkeitsnah.
Dieser art von wieder dein wort im mund umgedreht wird für alles was du sagst auf die goldwaage gelegt wird kann ich auch wiederum verstehen dass sie sagen da habe ich jetzt keinen bock drauf aber klar ein sehr viel,
wertvolleres statement pro julian assange könnte einfach von denen kommen ja und das ist natürlich schon richtig dass hier diese mälzer geschichte,
das große thema ist aber diese beiden irgendwie nach wie vor hier nicht so wirklich sich.
Öffentlich in dem ausmaß geäußert haben wie es jetzt hier melzer tut in die gleiche richtung kommentiert auch tapete.
Lieber linus danke für die detaillierte ausführung des machtmissbrauchs und der folter im fall,
nicht nur in bezug auf wahrung der menschenrechte auch im hinblick auf den umgang und die einordnung von fällen sexualisierter gewalt sind die geschehnisse bedenklich und werden dinge verändern deswegen hier mein details.
Ähm du sagtest doppelpunkt,
es teilte sich sehr früh in zwei lager ich überspitzt das jetzt mal die einen die sagten dass er eine reine verschwörung gegen julian assange und die anderen die sagen naja irgendwas wird schon dran gewesen sein und er kann ja ein,
grandioser anführer einer leading plattform sein und ein arschloch die meisten leute sagen er ist beides.
Das war jetzt zitat von mir von tapete und jetzt macht er bete weiter
da das thema so wichtig ist es auch wichtig wie darüber gesprochen wird arschloch sein ist für mich weit unter dem verhalten und das ist hier in der theorie geht ungeschütztes eindringen ist ebenso wie andere nicht können nicht
konsensuale sexuelle interaktion die natürlich weit von der schauer vergewaltigung im wald entfernt sind nicht ok niemals okay,
und weit mehr als ein arschloch sein ob das nun vergewaltigung heißt oder nicht tut dabei gar nichts zur sache aber.
Wenn du etwas überspitzt darstellst dann wünsche ich mir gerade im hinblick darauf wie schwierig es derzeit ist.
Akzeptanz für die betroffenen perspektive sexualisierter gewalt herzustellen dass die überspitzte variante der vergewaltigungsvorwurf e nicht,
als ein arschloch sein verharmlost wird sondern in dem zuge auch benannt wird man kann ja ein großartiger anführer einer leading plattform und ein vergewaltiger sexualstraftäter,
oder ehrliches sein ich kürz das an der stelle etwas ab,
weil ich glaube dass der nächste absatz sich ein bisschen wiederholt das ist natürlich nicht deine schuld weil du das,
so gesagt hast aber mit genauigkeit und reflexion der eigenen sprache kann viel arbeit geleistet werden wobei das ziel immer ist sexualisierte gewalt minimieren ein faires die betroffenen perspektive stärken das system zum umgang
sexualisierter gewalt etablieren und misstrauen gegenüber,
betroffenen ebenso wie die möglichkeit zu denunziation am besten ganz.
Diesen planeten verbannen.
Als gruß von tapete und das spiegelt ein bisschen wieder.
Wir haben auch relativ viele kommentare gehabt ich weiß nicht genau von wie vielen personenpersonennahverkehr auf jeden fall viele kommentare,
die mehr oder weniger von uns jetzt irgendwie einen abbilden und eine vollständige entschuldigung von julian assange verlangen.
Und insbesondere.
Quasi wir oder insbesondere sich bei mir darüber beklagt wird dass ich sehr betont habe dass es in diesem ganzen,
aktuellen auslieferungs verfahren um die fdp und die.
Coletta mörder geschichten geht quasi aus der zeit aus der julian assange veröffentlichungen noch nicht,
kontrovers waren also die waren damals auch schon kontrovers aber er als person und dieses dieses gesamte,
schweden kam erst danach und diese gesamten russland connections kamen erst danach und all das spielt in diesem verfahren keine rolle da wurde sich darüber beklagt dass ich das so sehr betone wobei ich
ehrlich gesagt sagen muss genau das gehört ja betont weil in den juristischen auseinandersetzungen die menschen haben.
Und die vor gericht verhandelt werden auch immer nur der sach fall behandelt wird und auch nur in dem sah fall werden deine rechte.
Sind deine rechte relevant ne du kannst also ein sagen wir mal ein.
Vergewaltiger sein ein verurteilter vergewaltiger und ein freigesprochen der mörder ja weil du einen mord nicht begangen hast eine vergewaltigung aber schon und beides sind vor einem gericht eben unterschiedliche.
Verfahren und deswegen habe ich das so betont fand ich jetzt eigentlich relativ.
Okay das so zu betonen aber anderen hat das nicht so gefallen deswegen wollte ich das jetzt auch nochmal kurz erwähnen.
Ja ich meine diese ganze geschichte ist ein totales mienenfeld so und letztlich bin ich zurück denke also erstens wir behandeln diesen assange.
Was heißt fall also assange als person und wikileaks als projekt im prinzip seit seit wir diesen podcast gestartet haben.
Ich glaube tatsächlich seit folge eins ja.
Und immer immer wieder aus den verschiedensten aspekten und ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig erinnern dass wir uns eigentlich überhaupt,
irgendwann mal so richtig auf eine seite geschlagen hätten weil's immer alles sehr schwierig war also sowohl,
der umgang ja also die methode von wikileaks hat von anfang an so fragezeichen aufgeworfen trotzdem.
War da eben auch immer sehr viel unterstützenswert des drin und die offengelegten sachen waren ja in der regel auch wirklich krass.
Also es ist ja nicht so dass jetzt diese informationen als solche vollkommen unwichtig gewesen wäre sind einfach kriegsverbrechen und,
zusammenhänge politischer verwerfung finanzieller ströme et cetera die einfach nennenswert sind und die auch auf internationaler bühne und unserer meinung nach,
diskutiert gehört so und dazu hat sich dann eben einfach noch dieses drama seiner person entwickelt wo es einfach auch für uns,
schwierig war da eine rolle zu finden und wir haben es dann eben auch teilweise mit,
humor probiert ja also wie sich das zum beispiel in diesem studio asana ding wiederspiegelt so dieses so ja jetzt ist er irgendwie equatorianische weil weil es eben einfach auch nicht so einfach ist.
Hier immer mit so einem klaren das ist gut dass es böse das ist richtig das ist falsch zu kommen also erstmal weil wir es nicht,
ob es heute nie hundertprozentig wissen wir sind keine insider
wir mögen dem thematisch irgendwie näher stehen als andere aber nicht so dass wir jetzt die ganze zeit irgendwie
mit ihm rumgehangen haben und ihn irgendwie kennen und ein guter kumpel ist und die ganzen storys von ihnen kennen geschweige denn mit irgendeiner anderen seite da groß rum konstruiert hätten und irgendwelche rechtlichen,
einsicht netten haben wir alles nicht sondern wir betrachten das einfach aus derselben perspektive heraus aus der ihr das auch alle betrachten können nämlich
nachrichtenlage berichte was drüber geschrieben wird was leute dazu denken plus natürlich was für uns selber so ein bisschen,
denken glauben meinen vielleicht wissen zu können oder eben auch so wenigen sachen wie
ereignissen die damals auf dem kongress passiert sind als er da war
für uns irgendwie noch heraus destillieren können bleibt einfach schwierig das zu bewerten und ich denke wir haben eigentlich die ganze zeit über einfach immer versucht diesen mittelgroß zu finden so ja vorwürfe benennen.
Aber eben auch.
Nichts genaues weiß man nicht offen lassen ob's so ist und wenn wir jetzt sozusagen immer flagge aus beiden seiten kriegen mit ihr verurteilt ihn aber nicht ausreichend oder ihr erkennt ihn nicht ausreichend als heiligen an sagen sie solange beides kommt,
wahrscheinlich sogar ganz ganz richtig in unserer ausrichtung.
Ja ich finde das sehr schön dass du das wäre irgendwie überhaupt gar keine ahnung von nichts also das
man muss jetzt nicht lange googeln um sich zusammen zu zählen dass wir wahrscheinlich schon auch den ein oder anderen kontakt haben den anderen nicht haben in diese richtung so.
Ja aber aber wir haben nichts zu tun genau.
Haben wir mit dem alten nichts zu tun und müssen also.
Ich zumindest bei diesem thema keine ahnung ich habe schon mal irgendwie diese ganzen sachen losging da ich das schon als journalist irgendwie bei netzpolitik org behandelt und,
diesen kram verfolgt man dann halt über jahre und ja das ist irgendwie dass vieles im wandel und da gab's so viele geschichten die wir hier auch nicht unbedingt.
Nochmal aufgerollt haben wie damals das ausscheiden von daniel domscheit-berg der bei uns sendungsmast auch schon mal war ne erinnern sich vielleicht einige dran und,
diesen ganzen kram das kann man natürlich auch nicht jedes mal alles würdigen und da kann ich auch ein bisschen nachvollziehen dass es dann leute gibt die sage ich mal.
Vielleicht ähnlich nah dran sind oder uns ähnlich nah dran vermuten die sich dann jedes mal ärgern wenn wir irgendwie den aspekt oder den aspekt da nicht mit berücksichtigt haben.
Insgesamt habe ich trotzdem den eindruck dass wir diesen ganzen kram immer.
Erstens schon von allen facetten versucht haben zu würdigen und das ist uns glaube ich auch immer ganz gut gelungen und.
Dass wir vor allem und das fand ich ganz interessant glaube ich dass wir der podcast sind ja darüber über die jahre am meisten gesprochen hat so also ich kenne
wenige veröffentlichungen die sich so intensiv mit mit assange immer wieder auseinandergesetzt haben inklusive uns glaube ich netzpolitik org nicht mehr also die glaube ich nicht dass sie sich noch
so viel über jeden kleinen assange furz unterhalten haben wie wir so
das ist schon eines unserer ja auch zugegebenermaßen meiner lieblingsthemen seit über einem jahrzehnt.
Ja also klar wir haben natürlich eine gewisse nähe zu personen und akteuren aber was ich meinte ist die vorgänge konkret in england und in schweden,
ja also alles was insbesondere nach seiner festsetzung passiert ist da haben wir keinen unmittelbaren einblick so und auch die leute die wir kennen halt in dem sinne.
Ich war auch nie in der botschaft.
Ich auch nicht.
Vor der tür ja.
Echt aha aha was hast du denn da gemacht.
Ich war vorher im harrys habe ich mir einen schönen pelzmantel.
Hallo.
Dann bin ich natürlich auch noch kurz irgendwie vor der vor der ecuadorianischen botschaft irgendwie vorbei.
Aha aha aha und damit der prinzessin durch den tunnel gefahren da muss man nochmal drüber reden.
Einmal einmal das handy in den einbuchen wird man ja wohl dürfen.
So bei der gelegenheit weisen wir nochmal hin auf die petition von reporter ohne grenzen die jetzt nämlich eine,
petition gemacht haben wir fordern großbritannien auf,
wikileaks gründer julian assange nicht an die usa auszuliefern dort drohen ihn bis zu einhundertfünfundsiebzig jahre haft allein dafür,
dass er internationalen medien informationen zur verfügung gestellt hat die von großen öffentlichen interesse waren die zeit drängt am vierundzwanzigsten februar,
beginnt in london die anhörung zum auslieferungs verfahren ja und da haben sie natürlich so viel kürzer,
kann man das auch nicht richtig zusammenfassen und bei der gelegenheit sei auch noch darauf hingewiesen dass es jetzt ein.
Jetzt auch nicht überraschende aber immerhin belegte erkenntnis gibt dass nämlich julian assange in,
den usa dann isolationshaft dient als maßnahme zur gefahrenabwehr ja,
also nicht zur bestrafung sondern den assad stehen den können wir nur,
isoliert festhalten weil der könnte ja aus der haft informationen veröffentlichen die die nationale sicherheit der usa gefährden könnten also mit anderen worten sage mal ein.
Wer sich mit wikileaks damals schon auseinandergesetzt hat kennt sicherlich noch das instrument fall ein relativ große datei.
Die kommentarlos veröffentlicht hat als torrent und die leute gebeten hat,
diese aufzubewahren sollte es einmal notwendig werden würden sie das passwort zu entschlüsseln dann mitteilen das ist natürlich schon auch eine ganz ganz coole maßnahme.
Das hatte ich ganz vergessen irgendwie was ist denn da drin mal linus was ist denn da drin und du weißt das doch bestimmt du hast doch da was doch doch du hast doch du warst auch vor der botschaft was hat da rumgestanden mit deinem pelz.
Es war eine größere datei das passwort sag ich dir nach der sendung so und dann.
Dass er da jetzt sagen die halt naja der könnte ja weitergehen hat ja auch aus ecuador aus der botschaft auch ist natürlich totaler unsinn weil
es ist ja schon so dass immer noch ein funktionierendes team hat und wenn der wenn der weg gekehrt hat wird dann werden sicherlich ganz andere leute würden
wenn es denn den auslöser gibt die passwörter zum influencer pfeil veröffentlichen oder weitere veröffentlichungen,
weiterführen und dann gibt es noch ein wichtiges statement wie ich denke von edward snowden in dem zusammenhang,
der sagte das verfahren gegen juden stellt einen preis präzedenzfall da denn nicht nur ihn
sondern auch unabhängigen und kritischen journalismus in allgemeinen kriminalisieren soll und snowden betont er vor allem einen wichtigen aspekt gegen assange hat die us-regierung viel weniger an der hand als gegen mich,
ich habe tatsächlich daten beschafft ich hatte einen vertrag mit der regierung.
Assange dagegen hat kein einziges dokument selbst geschafft er hat lediglich dokumente entgegengenommen trotzdem bekommt er weniger unterstützung als ich.
Wir müssen die freiheit des journalismus gerade dann verteidigen wenn er unbequem ist und uns nicht gefällt bequemer journalismus braucht unseren schutz in der regel nicht.
Sagte snowden wenn ich auch sehr wichtig nochmal also jetzt alle auf auf die petition von reporter ohne grenzen.
Alright.
Tim tim wusstest du übrigens dass es in den usa unterirdische militärbasen gibt in denen der teufel angebetet wird und kinder gefoltert.
Mir ist mir neu.
Hatte ich jetzt nur so in teilen bisher von gehört aber man hört ja immer wieder so sachen im netz das ist man weiß ja nicht.
Wenn man sich erstmal von den mainstream media verabschiedet hat dann hört man dann also und dann im internet ließ was wie es wirklich läuft ne.
Dann bleibt eigentlich nur noch ein schluss tja in hanau hat gestern.
Ein insel neun menschen.
In einer in in zwei shishabars in der hanauer innenstadt getötet danach seine mutter und zuletzt sich selbst.
Ja
Und die sandra die begründung die ihr dafür anführt ein manifest veröffentlicht und auch irgendwie eine reihe an videos die.
Von durchaus also je nachdem wie viel man schon getrunken hat unterhaltsam sein könnten aber eigentlich relativ schockierend tiefe.
Form von verschwörungstheorien und wahrscheinlich psychischer krankheit zeigen aber was ich ganz interessant finde ist,
also die wenigen sachen die ihr irgendwie als fakten benennt also neben dass er eine strategie für die usa entwickelt hat,
die ihm dann von einer ihn überwachenden organisation gestohlen wurde und jetzt gerade in den usa umgesetzt wird nämlich dass ein milliardär präsident ist und irgendwie für den dfb hatte er auch eine theorie wie er wieder.
Wie er wieder im fußball gewinnen könnte das wird ihm auch geklaut kommt er auf solche ideen wie das täglich ein deutscher,
täglich ein deutscher von einem ausländer getötet wurde was nicht stimmt ja also das stimmt nicht.
Es sind die letzte statistik die ich da irgendwie sowas von zwanzigsiebzehn weil das bier da erstmal angefangen hat.
Diese in den statistiken für mord und totschlag auch die nationalität der täter anzugeben in zweitausendsiebzehn sind einhunderteinunddreißig menschen ein mord oder totschlag zum opfer gefallen und dreiundachtzig.
Davon waren fälle in denen das opfer deutsch war.
Und ein nicht deutscher täter ermittelt wurde das also nicht einer pro tag sondern,
alle vier bis fünf tage macht einen unterschied für seine rechnungen die ihr rechnet das nämlich dann auf zehn zwanzig jahre hoch und meint hier werden irgendwie unmengen an menschen getötet.
Interessant ist solche und ähnliche fake statistiken verbreitet natürlich auch so jemand wie höcke sowas bietet die afd rauf und runter ne.
Und sowohl dieser mörder aus hanau.
Als auch höcke hängen der idee an und jetzt zitiere ich höcke.
Dass es irgendwie der volkstod der deutschen bevorsteht durch bevölkerungsaustausch dauert daraus hin zieht dieser.
Tobias er heißt er glaube ich in hanau,
dass die den schluss dass irgendwie sowas ich weiß jetzt irgendwie so weit wie zwanzig dreißig ethnien müssen jetzt ausgelöscht werden nicht nur aus dem land raus sondern also nicht nur aus deutschland heraus sondern vom planeten,
getötet werden müssen und das wäre es die grob säuberung zitat danach muss die feinen säuberung kommen diese betrifft die restlichen afrikanischen staaten süd und mittelamerika die karibik und natürlich das eigene volk wobei ich anmerken dass nicht jeder der heute einen deutschen pass besitzt reinrassisch und wertvoll ist
eine halbierung der bevölkerungszahl kann ich mir vorstellen schreibt er in seinem manifest.
Außerdem ja dass es irgendwie die irgendwelche unterirdischen us-militärbasis gibt und so weiter und so fort warum ich das jetzt so ein bisschen vergleiche mit den.
Thesen die zum beispiel von der afd oder insbesondere von der afd und ihren anhängern vertreten werden was jetzt fakten angeht nachvollziehbare fakten.
Die sind nicht so weit weg von dem was hier in wahrscheinlich geistig verwirrter mensch verbreitet hat und geglaubt hat und irgendwie durchgerechnet hat und in seinem manifest geschrieben hat.
Und.
Deswegen sollte man sich nicht so großartig davon ablenken lassen dass der typ ziemlich offensichtlich irgendwie auch einen an der waffel hatte neben der tatsache dass er eben ein rassistischer.
Mörder ist der.
In deutschland die bevölkerungszahl halbieren möchte weil nicht jeder ein reinrassisch wertvoller mensch ist.
Jetzt will ich gerne noch den begriff insel erklären im vorgespräch bin ich ganz ehrlich am tim und ich uns darauf geeinigt dass ich mich bemühe nicht so viele witze darüber zu machen in sales da steht für,
in volland harry also menschen die in einem unfreiwilligen zölibat leben.
Und in dem fall von diesem tobias eben zusehen müssen wie die herren rasse untergeht ohne dass sie für ihren fortbestand sorgen können.
Und ich glaube dass zumindest im fall von diesem tobias er er eben eine von denen jungfrauen ist die schon längst im himmel einem islamischen attentäter versprochen wurde.
Aber.
Jetzt ist es doch getan.
Und.
Ich habe da netzpolitik org hatte da auch glaube ich vor einigen wochen ein attentat ein podcast darüber das ist eben dass das eine zunehmende bevölkerungsgruppe ist die irgendwie ihre frustration,
darüber dass sie irgendwie keinen zugang zum anderen geschlecht finden.
Ausgerechnet in irgendwelchen fremdenfeindlichen theorien.
Und fremdenhass unterbringen und ich verstehe also und natürlich frauenhass ne also das natürlich erstmal.
Was heißt ausgerechnet also ich meine das ist ja nun wirklich alles tausend mal schon da gewesen so ich meine was,
aus aus solchen ich sag mal physischen situationen die das ja letztlich sind ja das ist ja jetzt nicht so ein so ein zustand von irgendwie,
reinheit jungfräulichkeit oder so etwas einfach eine physische situation für diese leute wird's halt,
wie nicht gewollt gemocht geliebt und hast einfach nicht diese diese erfahrung von von mehr oder weniger regelmäßiger,
näher und zuneigung und natürlich fragst du dich so okay was ist der grund und dieses ganze rassistische.
Öffentliche diskussion die halt nicht nur aber eben derzeit vor allem von der afd in die öffentlichkeit getragen wird das ist halt immer so dieser nährboden für,
du verstehst nicht warum du scheiterst hier sind einfache erklärungsmodel und es sind halt immer die anderen und diese ganze verschwörungstheorien.
Archiv was da noch nachgeliefert wird,
ist dann eben einfach auch so ein so ein wunderbares erklärungsmodell baustein system was keinerlei nennenswerten zusammenhang haben muss,
aus dem man sich dann einfach das passende herausgreift und am ende ist die rechnung eigentlich immer dieselbe die anderen sind schuld und die anderen sind halt die die man vor allem.
Klar als die anderen wahrnehmen kann hat eine andere hautfarbe hat ein anderes geschlecht kommt aus dem anderen land spricht eine andere sprache ist nicht aus meiner region mag mein fußballverein nicht was auch,
immer so einfacher erklärungsmodel so und die werden dann dankbar aufgenommen weil sie einem eben selber,
einerseits erstmal so ein einfaches erklärungsmodel liefert so ah ich bin ja gar nicht schuld an meinem eigenen elend,
ist ja gar nichts was mit was mit mir zu tun hat sonst,
ja von außen herangetragen mir wird ja ein unrecht zugefügt es darf ja gar nicht sein da muss ja was dagegen getan werden,
so schiebt man das dann einfach auch ab und
setze ich auch überhaupt nicht damit auseinander was man denn vielleicht an sich selber ändern kann um diese zustände für sich zu verbessern und legt es dann eben auf andere und dadurch dass es in dieser öffentlichen debatte und immer diesem ausdehnen des sagbaren immer weiter getrieben wird,
steigt das ist das wie so ein wie so ein durchlauferhitzer indem das einfach immer wieder immer wieder sich gegenseitig,
verstärkt und dann eben bei manchen leuten dann irgendwann einfach die sicherung durchbrennt und sie dann in so einem totalen wahnsinn,
in so einem amok eben übergehen und sagen oh gott oh gott oh gott es wird jetzt immer schlimmer.
Wenn jetzt nicht sofort was getan wird ja nach mir die sintflut dann bist du an diesem punkt.
Weil dieses phänomen ja gar nicht so,
so wenig verbreitet ist wie wahrscheinlich vielleicht menschen und vor allem die betroffenen denken würde ich hier so an der stelle ich will jetzt hier keinen großartigen dating ratgeber machen oder so ne aber,
wenn sich unter unseren hörern unfreiwillig zölibat äre befinden dann wäre mein erster tipp.
Euch nicht den rat bei denen zu holen die das gleiche problem haben sondern bei denen die das problem gelöst haben ja also irgendwie in dem,
insasse reddit wird euch sicherlich nicht der rat gegeben werden mit dem ihr euer leid lindert,
denn laut wikipedia wurden inzwischen vier massenmorde mit insgesamt fünfundvierzig toten von leuten verübt die sich als insel,
selber identifiziert und bezeichnet haben tatsächlich gilt muttis rad auf jeden topf was auch ein deckel.
Und es gibt eben sicherlich auch einige sehr gute ratgeber empfehlungen oder angebote in eurer stadt oder in eurer umgebung.
Um eurem zustand da ein ende zu bereiten statt den zum teil eurer identität werden zu lassen und ein guter,
guter gradmesser dafür wo ihr guten rat bekommt ist immer ob dieser rat,
irgendwo eine menschenverachtende komponente hat wenn er das hat dann ist es,
in der regel kein guter rat das gilt genauso für irgendwelche pickup-artist die irgendwie frauen als non player charakters irgendwie sehen die sie irgendwie nur aufreißen und zwar nach schema f.
Wie für irgendwelche spinner die sagen ihr müsst jetzt irgendeine andere rasse töten weil die euch die frauen wegschicken das ist alles unsinn ja es gibt,
mit sicherheit sehr guten rat der euch erklärt wie man
in welcher situation man sich begibt um vielleicht menschen kennenzulernen und wo man vielleicht auch menschen krieg findet die vielleicht ein ähnliches problem haben und ebenso daran interessiert sind
das problem zu lösen aber irgendwie nicht gerade,
ebenso auf der suche nach einem weg dahin sind und haltet euch bitte an solche ideen auch nicht nur damit ihr nicht irgendwann auf andere menschen schießt sondern auch weil es tatsächlich.
Mitunter erhalt eben schwere psychologische,
also der schweres psychisches leid und durchaus krude und unschöne konsequenzen hat wenn man sich eben zu lange in einer situation befindet in der man unglücklich ist und gerade wenn es um solche phänomene wertschätzung nähe,
sexualität geht dann geht das eben auch an manchen oder an vielen menschen nicht spurlos vorüber.
Also bitte sucht euch da rat von den leuten wie bei jedem anderen problem auch.
Kriegt man gelöst und am besten durch den rat von denen die das problem vor einem schonmal gelöst haben und nicht dem rat von denen die das gleiche problem einfach auch haben.
Ja jetzt hat natürlich der ganze fall eine.
Erneute öffentliche debatte ausgelöst wie wir das regelmäßig sehen die frage ist immer nur wie lange hält die debatte ja also hält sie bis zum nächsten news heikel oder vielleicht ausnahmsweise mal bis zum übernächsten news michael,
kann man derzeit jetzt noch nicht sagen er hat auf jeden fall mal wieder so eine andere.
Dimension ich hab zumindest den eindruck dass wir mal ein bisschen produktiver in die richtung schwenken mit wie soll eigentlich die debatte.
Diesen soll man denn diese leute nennen.
Wir sind ja jetzt nicht nur faschisten oder einfach so leute die einfach generell diese diese diese diese empörung,
nach außen tragen ob sie das jetzt bewusst mit einer agenda machen wie es sicherlich bei der afd der fall ist oder dir einfach nur nur mitschwimmen weil weil sie gar nicht reflektieren was sie eigentlich anstellen mit ihrer,
debatten kultur und die dann eben die leute die nicht so gefestigt in ihrem leben stehen dann einfach mitziehen,
es ist schwierig ich glaube nicht dass wir da schon angekommen sind aber ich denke wir müssen zumindest.
Mal anerkennen dass jetzt das thema der terror kommt gerade von rechts einfach mal in der dauer öffentlichen diskussion final verankern weil das.
Einfach so.
Hier der hans-georg maaßen hat ja noch an dem tag irgendwie antifa gleich nazis getwittert aber okay der ist auch glaube ich der scheint auch ich wollte ja keine witze über.
Das kann man das kann man mathematisch schnell auflösen also wer anti antifa ist das kürzlich das anti wegbleibt einfach noch fahr über.
Leider ja.
Kann man sich dann schnell kann man sich schnell ausrechnen was das ergibt.
Ja weiß nicht gibt's da für uns also netzpolitischen aspekte gerade nicht.
Na ja schon.
Na ja gut die debatte im netz.
Debatte im netz die debatte über hass im netz und natürlich die bevorstehende verschärfung des netzdg natürlich jetzt diese debatte wird jetzt genau vor dem hintergrund geführt werden.
Das stimmt auch wenn sie sowieso schon gerade geführt wird was worum geht's also dieses netzwerk,
durchsetzungsgesetz ein sehr fragwürdiger titel weil hier soll ja kein netzwerk durchgesetzt werden sollen hier sollen dinge im netzwerk durchgesetzt werden,
in den netzwerken.
Deswegen heißt es ja auch netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz.
Durchsetzungsgesetz heißt es netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz.
Ja das wird damit durchsetzt.
Okay durchsetzungsgesetz netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz wird das netzwerk durchgesetzt oder,
ich finde den namen trotzdem bekloppt also ich bin schon komplett durchsetzt von diesem begriff.
Da gab's ja von anfang an viel streit jetzt ist eine verschärfung dieses gesetzes geplant
weil man festgestellt hat dass da noch nicht so viel durchgesetzt wurde wie man sich das vielleicht vorgestellt hat.
Dieser vorschlag kommt aus dem justizministerium von unserer neuen justizministerin ministerin frau,
lamprecht hatten wir ja letztes mal schon festgestellt dass uns der name neu war
und ist jetzt wohl auch im kabinett schon beschlossen worden damit ist er natürlich noch lange nicht gesetzt weil einerseits muss es natürlich im bundestag bundesrat abgesegnet werden und vor allem gibt es halt auch noch keinen finalen
gesetzestext das was jetzt allerdings schon vorliegt das erfährt doch eine gewisse,
eine gewisse reflexion nämlich es wird sehr viel.
Kritisiert und bemängelt an diesem änderungen gesetz worum geht's jetzt eigentlich was soll getan werden.
Verschiedene dinge die gesetzesverschärfung soll unter anderem die anbieter von telemediendiensten und das heißt in dem fall halt,
facebook twitter aber eben auch keine ahnung twitter tinder oder,
whatsapp messenger dienste et cetera die sollen zur herausgabe von bestandsdaten gezwungen werden.
Können und das heißt es sind dann solche sachen wie ip-adressen aber auch in dieser debatte passwörter.
Mit anderen worten was hier gefordert wird ist ein.
Mittelbarer oder unmittelbarer direkter zugang zu einem account den man bei irgendeinem telemediendiensten besitzt.
Und das hat natürlich so einige implikationen außerdem soll es eine meldepflichten geben für die betreiber.
Das heißt das anders als derzeit wo ja
die betreiber quasi erst gezwungen sind auf etwas zu reagieren wenn sie denn darauf hingewiesen werden so hier da beleidigungen hier volksverhetzung etcetera dass sie dann entsprechend löschen innerhalb eines gewissen zeitraums das war ja im prinzip
das was die erste version dieses gesetzes formuliert hat dass das jetzt so weitergehend formuliert wird dass man sagt,
ihr müsst das jetzt selber feststellen ihr müsst selber quasi den besen in die hand nehmen und alles was irgendwie gesetzeswidrig sein kann,
selber bemerken und dann im zweifelsfall auch selber entfernen aber eben auch melden und das dann eben gekoppelt mit diesem bestandsdaten anders,
sodass das bka in dem moment quasi freihaus diese ganzen gesetzesverstöße,
erhält und dann bearbeiten kann da möchte man dann auch gerne das bka sachlich und personell aufstocken um,
ungefähr dreihundert neue stellen damit dann eben diese ganzen daten flut auch gearbeitet werden kann.
Passieren soll das ganze immer wenn es konkrete anhaltspunkte gibt also.
Ist jetzt immer schwierig zu sagen was sind das denn im einzelnen sein könnte aber so normale beleidigungen sein sollen da jetzt sozusagen nicht dabei sein also wenn du sagst du bist so ein arschloch linus
dann komme ich vielleicht noch davon weil facebook sagt so ja,
müssen wir ist halt so ja aber wenn ich halt jetzt hier irgendwie die umvolkung predige dann könnte es dann vielleicht dann doch schon eher mal sein dass hier eine meldung angemessen ist.
Und es gibt auch eine lösch pflicht also man muss sozusagen löschen und man muss es melden sich glaube ich auch schon gesagt ja,
die betreiber sind natürlich jetzt nicht so begeistert und drohen mit dem szenario dass jetzt hier eine umfassende datenbank beim blick über die nutzer,
und ihrer geposteten inhalte aufgebaut wird das und das ihres gleichen besucher dem kann man glaube ich.
Durchaus zustimmen weil es natürlich extrem schwierig ist diese,
feststellungen zu treiben ob jetzt irgendetwas gesetzeswidrig ist wir hatten das ja hier auch schon häufiger diskutiert also die privatisierung der gesetzesform setzung,
was was sind denn sozusagen die kriterien dafür wie soll man denn jetzt sozusagen als betreiber umgehen wie wie wie wie gut funktioniert ein ironie detektor in einem kontext ja ob ein,
eine nachricht jetzt sozusagen war,
und irgendwie nur versucht vielleicht schlecht formulierten aber trotzdem gut gemeinten witz zu machen oder ob eben hier tatsächlich eine bedrohung vorliegt das kann man ja einen text.
Nicht unbedingt immer so ansehen kann ein zitat sein etcetera also da gibt's eine menge probleme.
Das grundsätzliche problem hier ist natürlich dann diese forderung nach bisschen medienberichten oft heißt die passwörter sollen herausgegeben werden das ist natürlich insofern ganz lustig als das natürlich die passwörter in dem sinne eigentlich gar nicht herausgegeben,
werden können beziehungsweise eigentlich nicht herausgegeben werden,
können sollten weil es ja eigentlich die pflicht gibt diese passwörtern gar nicht im klartext zu speichern passwörter werden eigentlich,
in der regel als sogenannte also quasi also krypto ergebnisse der passworteingabe
gespeichert was aber letzten endes auch gleich hinaus werden laufen könnte also man könnte ja sozusagen auch sagen ja okay ihr wollt zugang zu diesem account haben dann,
dann stellen wir den euch einfach bereit ja wir müssen euch ja keinen passwort geben,
sondern ihr könnt ja dann einfach den zugang haben also dann sprechen wir eigentlich ja von einer backdoor und das wäre wahrscheinlich auch,
jetzt mal aus perspektive formuliert sehr viel praktischer weil man stellt sich jetzt mal vor es könnte tatsächlich
passwort weitergegeben werden und dann würde eben die polizei in irgendeiner form dieses passwort zum einsatz bringen das hätte ja dann diesen schönen nebeneffekt,
dass dann vielleicht darauf hingewiesen werden so ja eine ip-adresse aus einer stadt bei hohen anteil hat sich in deinen account eingeloggt und so das ist ja sozusagen auch nicht das was die leute an der stelle wollen.
Also was du noch dazu hast ist es gibt ja eine reihe leute die aus irgendwelchen völlig nicht nachvollziehbaren wahnsinnigen gründen an verschiedenen accounts das gleiche passwort benutzen.
Richtig genau das könnte sozusagen auch noch dazu führen dass es eben nicht nur eine einzige zugang geöffnet wird sondern eben mehrere oder im schlimmsten fall sogar alle.
Das gilt es natürlich auch zu vermeiden aber was heißt denn das eigentlich also wenn man sich das jetzt mal.
Nehmen wir mal facebook ne weil das ja immer so ein bisschen das naheliegendste ist ja jetzt nicht das einzige was jetzt hier davon betroffen wäre aber es ist natürlich klar dass es hier vor allem auch vor allem um um um facebook geht oder vielleicht eben auch vor allem um twitter.
Da es ist ja auch nicht alles öffentlich das in dem moment wo man im zugang zum account schafft,
hier ist zwar von bestandsdaten die rede aber in dem moment wo man von passwort redet redet man ja quasi von einem vollständigen,
dort zugang zu einem zum account und eben der möglichkeit voller einblicke über wann wurde was wo veröffentlicht,
dazu einen zugang zu geben heißt es ja auch okay dann sind aber auch die privaten nachrichten dabei.
Wenn ich irgendwie facebook messenger sehe dann sehe ich halt alles was ich in allen gruppen und alles was ich eben privat gemacht habe auch noch ist natürlich ein riesen problem.
Das größte problem an dieser angelegenheit scheint mir zu sein also was ich ohnehin nicht so ganz verstehe unter normalen bedingungen,
ist es ja es ist ja nicht so als wären unsere social-media-accounts was weiß ich facebook nachrichten oder.
Facebook-post oder so jetzt irgendwie zum heutigen zeitpunkt sicher vor polizeilichen zugriff ja,
beispiel übrigens hier wikileaks wenn man sich zurück erinnert aber gab es auch ein loch für ewigkeiten behandelt diese sapina an twitter und.
Facebook e-mail und sonstiges die national security wetters über die nicken marcel auch beim kongress beim siebenundzwanzigste drei erstmalig gesprochen hat wo wo es eben auch diese geheimen daten anforderungen gab und es.
Es ist ja nicht so als wären jetzt deine bestandsdaten außer dem passwort also angemeldete ip-adressen port nummern und so weiter gerade.
Vor polizeilichen zugriff geschützt ja wenn irgendwie wenn ein dritter account hast kann die polizei selbstverständlich sagen auf welche e-mail-adresse ist der registriert und kannst du dem email-anbieter gehen,
versuchen herauszufinden.
Von welcher ip diese e-mails zugegriffen wurden und dadurch herauszufinden beim provider von von wem dieser account ist ja aber für diese zugriffe brauchen sie einen richterlichen beschluss.
Und wenn hier jetzt mit dieser novelle des netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetzes,
plattformen verpflichtet werden diese inhalte nicht nur zu löschen sondern direkt an das bka zu melden inklusive passwort und nutzer daten.
Dann wird quasi auf einmal diese bestandsdaten abfrage.
Findet dann ohne richter vorbehalt auf initiative des des netzwerkes statt und das ist ja die vollkommene vollkommene verdrehung es ist ja nicht so als gäbe es diesen zugriff nicht.
Sondern dass jetzt ohne richter vorbehalt einfach volles pfund es ist da dran geben darf es gibt also keine keine hürden einfach.
Geht einfach los und dann noch dazu eben zu diese erhöhung des strafmaßen für diese beleidigende dinge ja es soll jetzt mehrjährige haftstrafen.
Sollen in sozialen medien geäußerte drohungen beleidigungen verleumdungen kommen dann halt unter strafgesetze und können halt bis zu mehrjährige haftstrafe nach sich ziehen das ist wahrscheinlich notwendig oben überhaupt diese ganzen sofortmaßnahmen halt
auch juristisch.
Rechtfertigen zu können vielleicht sagen würdest ok bleibt eine ordnungswidrigkeit aber du musst gemeldet werden wer das eben,
nicht so ohne weiteres möglich brauchst du schon ordentliche strafmaß für und,
also das ist schon grade in so einem ermittlungsverfahren das irgendwie so zu automatisieren also das klingt schon ziemlich skurril und.
Das haben wir bei bei anderen ähnlich weit greifenden maßnahmen nicht insbesondere bestandsdaten auskunft geht nach meiner kenntnis nicht ohne richter vorbehalt.
Also auch das ist nur so ein kurzer papier akt aber.
Ja der die feierabend festigkeit von so richter vorbehalten sind ja auch berühmt also das ist sozusagen wenn da noch mal schnell eine unterschrift geleistet werden soll dann ist das selten das problem ist nicht so dass da,
sich richter dann ausführlich mit diesem fall beschäftigen und immer gucken ob das irgendwie passt.
Dann gibt es bei solchen maßnahmen natürlich immer auch da erinnern wir uns an die debatten hier funk zellen transparenz dem funktionellen abfrage telefone abgehört dass es eine benachrichtigung gibt.
Aber die kann natürlich auch irgendwie die wird ja immer nur dann findet ja nur dann statt wenn.
Keine überwiegenden schutz würdigen belange dem gegenüber stehen oder ermittlungstechnisch belange das heißt in der regel werden betroffene noch nicht mal darauf darüber informiert.
Und das noch alles vor dem hintergrund wo alle wissen es geht nicht weißt du.
Die herausgabe von passwörtern zumindest wer worüber diskutieren wir hier oder warum diskutieren wir jetzt hier über so etwas ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht dass man zwanzig.
Neunzehn ist ist der regierung immer noch gelingt so ein gesetzesentwurf zu verabschieden ins parlament herunter zu erreichen.
Entschuldigung krass oder.
Du meinst jetzt weil's ja diese passwörter gar nicht geben darf.
Laut dsgvo würden diese unternehmen eine eine,
was weiß ich ordnungswidrig erwähnen auf jeden fall gehen dass die dsgvo verstoßen wenn sie passwörter ohne ohne unbeherrscht oder unverschlüsselt und gesichert irgendwie aufbewahren würden.
Also mit anderen worten gesetz der gleichen der gleichen regierung des gleichen landes das gleiche staates.
Verbietet diese speicherung von passwörtern ist auch gut und jeder mensch der mal für eine mark mitgedacht hat verbietet die speicherung von passwörtern und in diesem gesetzesentwurf steht am laufenden band die passwörter müssen mitgeteilt werden die passwörter mitnehmen müssen mitgeteilt werden.
Niemandem ist klar warum denn überhaupt ja die daten die da sind die sind ja ohnehin zugreifbar mit,
unterricht der vorbehalte das wiederum ist er aber scheint ja genau der teil zu sein die ich in mich weg ist weil.
Der hier wegfallen sollten zwar gezielt die anbieter sind verpflichtet das sofort an das melden
ohne dass überhaupt jemand eine anzeige erstattet hat wegen dieses kommentare ohne dass eine richterin diese diese sache geprüft hat und gesagt hat okay das ist ein.
Ist ein fall den wir uns anschauen wollen und das ist keiner ja all das wird fällt fällt einfach ausm weg freihaus daten lieferung an das bka weil du was freches getwittert oder facebook hast,
das ist völlig also man fragt sich ernsthaft wer auf so eine idee kommen kann ja und jetzt dann hören wir uns doch mal an,
wie wir gerade im feuer in hanau natürlich haben wir ein problem mit rechtem hass und auch dieser hanau täter hat eben seinen ganzen unsinn den er da glaubt.
Aus dem internet und den stimmen in seinem kopf.
Und aus talkshows.
Ok und wo dann also wo auch immer der das her hat ja und ich will jetzt nicht behaupten dass das internet gerade irgendwie ein besonders friedfertiges ort wäre und dass man da dass man da keine probleme
hätte aber dann fragen wir doch mal jemanden der mit hass im internet ein problem hat zum beispiel renate künast so was sagt renate künast,
ja wir erinnern uns renate künast die irgendwie
als schlampe und die man irgendwie töten sollte was auch immer beschimpft wird und in den ersten instanzen oder den ersten verfahren jetzt zum glück irgendwie wieder neu aufgerollt werden so wie gesagt bekommen hat als wäre eine äußerung in der sache gewesen.
Das ist ja die situation die eigentlich das problem ist die sagt dazu bei der geplanten meldepflichten hasskommentare an das bka,
setzt der gesetzentwurf auf eine pauschale und umfangreiche weitergabe von daten der nutzerinnen und nutzer ohne vorliegen eines anfangsverdacht
da sagt sagt kritisiert selbst
renate künast manuel höfer fdp anstatt effektiv gegen online hetze vorzugehen
wird eine verdachts datenbank beim bka aufgebaut in der inhalte und zugehörige ip-adressen gespeichert werden und verdachts datenbank ist genau das das richtige hier ja die gehen
die schätzen also das justizministerium selber die den die den quatsch verzapft hat geht von einer.
Viertel millionen meldungen im jahr aus zweihundertfünfzigtausend meldungen im jahr wer soll das denn alles machen wir gehen ja also wir gehen ja,
entweder wenn jetzt ernsthaft sagen das sind hier schwere straftaten drohungen beleidigungen verleumdung ja und wenn sie dann davon ausgehen dass hier diese mit dem erhöhten,
strafen was versehenen straftaten zweihundertfünfzigtausend mal,
im jahr stattfinden dann können wir und du die jetzt sagen bis zu mehrjährige haftstrafe dann können wir jetzt mal neue knäste bauen ja weil das ist das wird dir genau nicht der fall sein insofern hat verliehen ja recht,
wenn er sagt das ist ja dann am ende eine verdachts datenbank also das ist doch total also bei allem,
bei aller kritik die ich an diesen ganzen hass im netz habe aber wenn wir von wat ist dat denn sechshundert,
sechshundert siebenhundert sechshundertachtzig oder so solcher schwert straftaten pro tag ausgehen müssen die dann in der datenbank des bka,
gesammelt werden dann können sie aber auch schon mal echt nochmal eine sechshundertachtzig polizisten mehr einstellen die jeden tag ein so ein fall behandeln und denn und die leute in knast bringen und dann können wir schon mal neue knäste bauen,
und was was wenn diese datenbank jedes jahr um eine viertel million passwörter steigt.
Ja was was und hier steht ja nichts von irgendwelchen löschfrist oder so das ist doch,
das ist doch wirklich mit kanonen,
auf auf auf das falsche geschossen auf die mit kanonen auf die falschen spatzen geschossen.
Während und das ne wo uns ja mal konkret konkret gezeigt wird dass uns eine politik gegen rechts fehlt,
wenn du dir mal guckst gibt's irgendwo nennenswerte budgets gegen gegen.
Solche rechten organisationen gibt's ein organisiertes klares irgendwie vorgehen gegen hass schon jetzt schaffen die es ja mit dem zur verfügung stehenden ressourcen was soll ich jetzt mit so einer passwort datenbank.
Was ist mit aussteiger projekten was ist mit aufklären aufklärung was ist mit meiner sondern kommission der polizei.
Dinos das problem ist doch das ist das problem ist doch der linksextremismus also es gibt ja leute die ja die sind ja.
Es gibt leute die werfen steine auf autos so verkommen sind.
Ja und auf und auf nazis das ist ja der totale linksextremismus bei der erinnern wir uns wir haben hier wie hieß doch gleich diese cdu ministerin diese junge die dann irgendwann wieder gedüst ist.
Die mit der schweinewarm die irgendwie im fernseher falsch umgeschaltet hat.
Nein unsere ehemalige familienministerin die halt im osten die ganzen maßnahmen gegen gegen rechte im osten,
die kohle gesperrt hat,
eigentlich ist auch vollkommen egal auf jeden fall haben wir in den letzten zwanzig jahren eben ein rückgang der finanzierung all dieser projekte geführt so weil immer dieser mythos hochgehalten wird so ja.
Entweder da ist ja nix.
Oder eben das fördert ja sozusagen antifa ist ja sozusagen linksextremismus und.
Die wurden ja dann gezwungen irgendwie so ein schwur zu leisten und dann durften sie nicht mehr mit irgendwelchen anderen linken strukturen zusammenarbeiten damit da nicht damit er nicht der antifaschistische terror,
gefördert wird wir haben auch in den in den shownotes einen schönen tee t wo mal gezeigt wird eben morde.
Von linken und morde von rechten.
Blöde ist dass ich nicht genau ich konnte jetzt nicht sehen wer denn überhaupt diese drei linken morde sind habe ich nicht mehr recherchiert vor beginn der sendung.
Aber das verhältnis ist also drei morde von linken in den letzten zwanzig jahren und ähm.
Zweihunderteinundachtzig morde von irgendwelchen nazis.
In dem gleichen zeitraum so das ist ja relativ klar das ist ja fast das gleiche.
Wenn man ein bisschen älter ist gehe ich nun leider.
Zweihundert jahren.
Auch dazu und und noch so sich so ein bisschen zurück erinnern kann wie das damals ende der siebziger jahre in deutschland ablief als diese ära.
Die ja auch.
Abgedreht waren und die auch in so einem sich in so einem feindes bild verrannt haben und dann angefangen haben halt politiker ab zu knallen.
Was dafür ein heckmeck gemacht wurde wie da der staat hochgefahren wurde wieder polizeigesetze erfunden wurden und,
diese ganzen überwachungsfans asien im prinzip gestartet wurden und ja also wie sich der staat richtig auf die hinterbeine gestellt hat und es einfach nichts anderes mehr gab
als irgendwie terror muss bekämpft werden und jetzt schaut man sich im prinzip den denselben scheiß faktor zehn.
Gefühlt seit zwanzig jahren an und sagt wieso ist sie nix wo denn was denn ich sehe nix.
Und das ist das was einen irgendwie wirklich was mich vor allem beunruhigt.
Und dann halt so nummern wie in thüringen wo die einfach auch ganz offensichtlich.
Überhaupt nicht checken was ihr da überhaupt tun egal ob es da die fdp oder die cdu ist beide lamentieren ja nur dumm rum und schwafeln irgendwas von irgendeiner linken gefahr und was ist die linke gefahr.
Ja bodo ramelow.
Hallo.
Bodenständig ministerpräsidenten der irgendwie dieses land auch mehr oder weniger ruhig geführt hat und.
Die rote.
Und damit die rote gefahr ja und dann wird da irgendwie von kultur marxismus und und und was nicht alles einfach geredet und damit im prinzip genau.
Diese spruch ebene der rechten weiter gestärkt und dann.
Haben die einfach blut anfänger das kann man glaube ich auch mittlerweile gar nicht mehr anders sagen.
Das das ist nicht nur so ein rumschaut wenzel oder so sondern man macht sich dann halt einfach mitschuldig.
An diesen toten in hanau und an all den anderen toten die wir in den letzten jahren gesehen haben und nicht nur den toten sondern es werden auch viele leute überfallen es werden viele leute verletzt es werden viele leute bedroht.
Wenn man sich mal anschaut ich meine warum sind denn auch so viele leute aus dem osten es geht jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit in detail erklärung so aber so.
Wer wer seine jugend im osten verbracht hat berichtet halt oft einfach von dieser.
Permanenten angst die im raum ist weil einfach so eine kulturelle hoheit der der der nazis in den in den dörfern in den städten in den schulen herrscht.
Die einfach,
dieses denken prägen und alle leute die in irgendeiner form anders sind da also entweder sind sie halt irgendwie links und freiheitliche orientiert oder eben halt einfach,
die anderen im sinne von die ausländer die schwulen die anderen die frauen die dann eben einfach unter dieser,
herrschaft zu leiden haben und dass die politik ist nicht scharf da nach nach zwanzig jahren nach dem wirklich,
alles sehr offensichtlich herumliegt auch nur im ansatz mal mit maßnahmen zu reagieren
zu sagen okay wir müssen alle vielleicht mal gegenhalten wir müssen da vielleicht mal in die schulen rein müssen vielleicht mal projekte vermissen einfach die möglichkeit geben was zu machen und wir müssen auch konsequent einfach,
das strafrechtlich verfolgen was einem auch was dem staat auch beim nsu nicht gelungen ist.
Und bei vielen anderen sachen auch nicht gelungen ist in der polizei nicht gelingt nicht im in der bundeswehr nicht gelingt auf allen ebenen nicht,
gelingt das ist einfach ist einfach erschreckend und es kann so nicht weitergehen also es ist einfach ich erwarte einfach denselben aufstand den dieser staat ende der siebziger jahre gemacht hat in seinem hass auf auf den linken terror,
einfach auch auf den rechten terror und wenn er es nicht tut dann muss ich leider sagen nähert sich in mir der verdacht dass er dem näher steht.
Als es sein sollte.
Er ist echt stark ne also gerade okay das ist die mitte die zeitliche kunst mit hanau ist natürlich ein,
zufall jetzt irgendwie aber gerade eine lübke mord und und dieses netzwerk dieser hannibal verschwörung da in der bundeswehr wo die also wirklich würdet das liest ja und denkst dir so,
alter vater also der der der.
Hanauer täter war ja waffenbesitzer der hat eine ganz normale neun millimeter pistole mit der das gemacht hat die hat ja so recht mir rechtmäßig besessen und in der bundeswehr gibt's da irgendwelche trepper die sich irgendwie warm machen für den tag x,
an dem sie irgendwie die straßenreinigung wieder vornehmen wollen und das sind so seite drei nachrichten,
und dann irgendwie so ja was müssen wir jetzt machen ja und den nsu der hat hier irgendwie die ganzen morde begangen und so und irgendwie die nazis sitzen im bundestag so was müssen wir machen ja lass mal
passwörter passwort datenbank beim brauchen wir jetzt als er fragst du dich doch wirklich.
Also der der fragt man sich ernsthaft ob die also das kann man ja gar nicht mehr mit mit mit inkompetenz erklären,
das kann man ja nur noch mit mit mit vorsätzlicher dummheit erklären anders kann ich mir wirklich langsam nicht mehr vorstellen.
Bleiben wir bei vorsätzlicher dummheit oder.
Ich weiß nicht haben wir zu diesem netz änderungen ding schon alles gesagt keine ahnung es gibt lange statements von patrick breyer dazu von piraten der sich da natürlich ausführlich mit auseinandergesetzt hat
ansonsten sind irgendwie alle parteien auch die grünen im wesentlichen irgendwie dafür habe ich so den eindruck mal schauen.
Wie das ausgeht.
Also wenn hier eine situation geschaffen wird man darf ja eines nicht vergessen.
Und da muss man sich einmal kurz von dieser hass debatte auch lösen wenn hier in deutschland eine situation geschaffen wird die.
Plattformen nicht nur.
Ermächtigt sondern verpflichtet meine ihnen anvertrauten daten,
ohne mir bescheid zu sagen auf verdacht nicht auf anforderungen sondern auf verdacht proaktiv und eigeninitiativ an das bka zu melden.
Dann werde ich mir ernsthaft überlegen welchen plattform ich noch angehören möchte denn was wir mit jeder einzelnen solcher.
Maßnahmen,
feststellen ist dass sie danach ausgeweitet werden das kommt heute mit hass und hetze das kommt morgen mit was weiß ich regierungskritisch in äußerungen oder was weiß ich oder,
like auf irgendetwas oder retreat auf irgendetwas oder was weiß ich an der ampel falsch abgebogen durfte man gar nicht links abbiegen und wer das jetzt irgendwie für beknackt hält oder irgendwie.
Nicht zutreffend die leute können sich ja mal die erfahrung mit dem staatstrojaner anschauen,
wo es ebenso losging mediale machen wir nur im schwersten fällen hier kinderpornografie und terror ne dann machen wir staatstrojaner und inzwischen sind wir bei der alltags kriminalität angelangt,
nur zehn jahren und da wird man sich ernsthaft überlegen müssen ob man,
unter dem einflussbereich deutscher juristin aktionen noch irgendwelche accounts haben möchte also dieses dieses gesetz ist gehen wir mal von diesem passwort unsinn weg,
auch dieses initiativ selber an das bka melden und das bka speichert die daten dann dort das ist schon.
Verrückt genug und ich mag diese symptomatische behandlungen nicht ja es wird.
Das war ja auch übrigens.
Auch in der wissenschaft keine selten vertretende meinung wenn man sich erst mal so anschaut dass jetzt alle davon ausgehen dass dieser rechtsradikale hass im netz die nazis geschaffen hätte nein.
Das ist nicht so die haben die waren vorher schon da die haben jetzt nur internet und es ist natürlich verschiebt sich hier das das.
Die möglichkeit der oder der der pegel dessen was man als akzeptabel noch
entgegennimmt und den muss ich auch die gesellschaft entgegenstellen das heißt aber nicht so dass nur weil du jetzt auf einmal im netz irgendwie die hetze stärker einnimmst dass diese nazis auf einmal wieder weg wären und da muss man
ansetzen das ist der unterschied zwischen einer ursächlichen behandlungen und zwischen und einer.
Und einer symptomatische behandlung und solange hier eine renate künast als prominente person die mit ihrem fall schon vorher medienöffentlichkeit hat.
Keine gerechtigkeit für die ihr widerfahren beschimpfungen erhält dann ist das das problem und nicht dass irgendwelche passwort herausgeben oder sonstiges.
Tja da hilft nur noch datenabfragen daten abfrage überall überall datenabfragen.
Ja aber es geht noch nicht mal mehr um eine abfrage es geht darum dass sie die schon haben sollen,
das ist der das ist der krasse punkt ja sollen sie von mir aus abfragen dann kriegen sie ein bisschen mit richter vorbehalt ist ja schon niederschwellig genug,
jetzt soll es darum gehen dass sie das schon haben die machen morgens ihren computer auf und haben jeden tag sechshundertachtzig neue meldungen in der inbox nachschärfungen des justizministeriums.
Crime abo kriegen das jetzt einfach perfekt das ist so ein.
Ja genau ja kann man das nicht als abonnieren.
Crime feed ja hallo facebook und tag wir möchten hier ist das bier möchten gerne ihren crime free feed haben weil wir haben jetzt keinen bock selber mehr zu gucken.
Nein nein du guckst in deine crime line.
Hallo.
Genau.
Die creme.
Hab ich habe ich in der kneipe gesehen also es war nicht so schnell was du da gesagt hast schau mal müssen wir mal ein bisschen was machen da müssen wir mal eine maßnahme beschließen oh mann.
Apropos heimlein wir haben in der letzten sendung schon über roger store gesprochen.
Der hat auch eine richtige crime.
Der hat auch echt 'ne fette crime gezogen der also roger stone bekannt dafür dass er kein hinterkopf hat dafür aber nichts ein tattoo auf dem,
hinten auf dem rücken und auch schon bekannt ist aus dem watergate skandal also der mann hat tradition und prinzipien.
Der hat früher schon für paul manafort gearbeitet
der wegen betruges ja sitzt der also auch so eine so ein so ein beißender der der der ganzen maler report und campaign finance sachen ist mit trump seit den achtziger jahren bekannt der wurde also ihm wurde.
Wurde jetzt verurteilt wegen falschaussagen behinderung von ermittlungen beeinflussung von zeugen in zusammenhang,
mit kontakten zur entwicklungsplattform wikileaks und zwar war das so roger stone hat ähm.
Den also war der kontakt.
Von dem unter anderem in twitter-account wikileaks in diesem zusammenhängen mit veröffentlichung der clinton e-mails und.
Die ankläger also wurde er stand vor einem bundesgericht in washington ist eben eine der ergebnisse des maler- reports und.
Wurde die ankläger haben angesichts der schwere seiner vergehen eine haftstrafe von sieben bis neun jahren gefängnis empfohlen,
dann hat das war ging dann irgendwie,
in den medien dann hat er also so eine forderung ist ja dann öffentlich öffentliches gerichtsverfahren danach trump das aufm klo gelesen hat getwittert hat gesagt das ist hier eine verfehlung der justiz.
Ein so hohes strafmaß für so einen feinen gentleman und.
Dann ist etwas passiert was ja selten passiert das justizministerium hat sich nämlich gegen die empfehlung seiner staatsanwälte gestellt und hat erklärt.
Dass der vorschlag der ankläger exzessiv und ungerechtfertigt sei diese formulierung exzessiv und ungerechtfertigt ist deshalb interessant weil es eben in den usa diesen passus in der.
Verfassung gibt gegen crew panisch moment also das strafmaß muss immer angemessen sein und das justizministerium hat dem gericht dann ein deutlich geringer strafmaß.
Empfohlen als von den eigenen staatsanwälten die sich mit dem fall befasst worden.
Vorgeschlagen wurde die vier staatsanwälte haben daraufhin ihren rücktritt erklärt und jetzt fiel das urteil.
Mit vierzig monaten haft,
statt der ursprünglich geforderten sieben bis neun jahre weil die staatsanwälte staatsanwälte die diese strafen gefordert haben eben zurückgetreten sind weil ihr eigenes ministerium ihnen den rücken gefallen ist.
Totaler wahnsinn oder.
Ja das ist so die die neue säuberung die da jetzt stattfindet weil es ist nicht
komplett neu trump hat ja auch öffentlich mehrfach schon damit angegeben dass er
jede gelegenheit nutzt richter position neu zu besetzen und die party vielleicht noch nicht neu besitzen die sind jetzt im modus voraus einer gehorsam um nicht neu besitzt zu werden und es scheint ganz gut zu funktionieren also.
Und die.
Die können sich ja eltern fragen und sagen na ja was bringt eigentlich jetzt vierzig monate oder neun jahre hin schreibe der wird doch eh übermorgen begnadigt von präsidenten das ist nämlich das was jetzt als nächstes passieren wird.
Der trump wird den begnadigen rucki zucki und,
in den usa hat sich dann noch eine längere debatte darüber entfaltet darf eigentlich der trump dem william bar es ist ein justizminister die anweisungen geben.
Diese diese strafmaß der irgendwie geringer zu fordern und so und na ja sieht so aus ja kann er,
ist immerhin sein justizminister der ist ja nur deshalb minister damit der präsident die arbeit nicht machen muss das ist die idee von ministern und wenn die da irgendwie nicht nach der wenn sie dem präsidenten nicht mehr gefallen dann müssen sie eben was anderes machen.
Und genauso ist das mit mit ministern in deutschland ebenso und das ist übrigens das was man,
eine behinderung der justiz nennt abstraktion of justice wenn der präsident da rein funkt und sagt hey das ist aber ein kumpel von mir und dieses gerichtsverfahren insgesamt ist mir sowieso ein bisschen viel zu nah an meiner position dran.
Und mein problem dran ja ich habe hier gerade ein impeachment wegen dieser überstanden und habe interessanterweise kein impeachment wegen des mannes reports gehabt.
Alter da geht es rund in den usa das sind wirklich so unanständige menschen.
Und es geht ja noch weiter wir bleiben beim thema wir bleiben bei den ganzen wikileaks veröffentlichung denn.
Im rahmen der anhörung hier julian assange,
und die eben jetzt am am montag beginnt eben dieses auslieferungs verfahren da hat jetzt der edward fit ein,
einer von julian assange anwälten kundgetan also das hat der gesagt weil der song nicht mehr in der lage sich zu äußern der fummelt irgendwie nur noch mit seinen brillen rum,
weil er eben wie auch nichts mehr gemeldet hat da durch ist,
der schilderte also jetzt das team von assange schildert das zweitausendsiebzehn ihm ein,
präsident shepard angeboten wurde,
auch genau das worüber wir letzte sendung noch oder vorletztes jahr noch gequatscht haben ja und zwar in diesem fall von dem damaligen republikanischen,
repräsentative also ein mitglied des kongress der.
Ah ja also man schreibt es danach rohrbach und man spricht glaube ich diana baker oder bachelor aus keine ahnung.
Ja ist halt deutscher stamm dahaben wir danach robert das ist so ein ganz.
Genau danach wacher klassischer name in deutschland der rohrer bacher dana so der hat.
Ihm ein eine begnadigung eben in aussicht gestellt wenn er öffentlich sagen würde,
die russen nicht in das e-mail league involviert waren dass hillary clinton damals ebenso stark geschadet hat in der kampagne zwanzig sechzehn gegen trump,
dann hat sich stephanie grisham die sprecherin des weißen hauses.
Quasi hingestellt und hat das geleugnet und der rohrbach hat dann gesagt ja.
Es stimmt was hier der der anwalt von der sorge sagt aber ich habe niemals mit dem präsidenten über assange gesprochen ich habe mir zwar die mühe gegeben dass mit dem,
mit dem assange auszuhandeln und das.
Auch servierfertig dem dem weißen haus übergeben ja aber ich habe nur angeboten dass ich dann mit trump reden würde und das weiße haus hat dann aber nicht mehr geantwortet.
Alles so korrupten vögel er ist echt unglaublich.
Alter sind das korrupte schweine oder ich meine es ganz eindeutig jeder weiß der hat das im zweifelsfall gemacht weil der trump ihm gesagt hat dass er es machen soll.
Er redet ja er hat ja auch offenbar regel regen kontakt zu trump und trump hat überall irgendwelche hampelmänner rumrennen in zweifelhaften positionen er lässt seine kleine sache klären von irgendwie rudy giuliani ist ein siebzigjähriger
ein ehemaliger anwalt und bürgermeister der überhaupt keine position hat in der regierung.
Niemand gewählt hat der als trumps persönlicher anwalt in der ukraine rumrennt und irgendwie.
Irgendwelche deals versucht er zu erpressen,
und genauso rennt natürlich irgend so ein irgend so ein rohrbach da bei assange rein und sagt aber pass mal auf willst du nicht irgendwie mal sagen,
die russen hätten damit nichts zu tun weil du bist natürlich ist ja ganz klar,
assange wäre die naheliegendste glaubwürdigste quelle dafür in der öffentlichkeit jeder andere weiß dass wikileaks im zweifelsfall wirklich nicht weiß wo sie die e-mails her haben oder sagen wir mal vielleicht wissen sie es aber sie können es sicherlich nicht beweisen,
ob sie es von den russen haben oder nicht und genau das wäre natürlich wunderschön gewesen für für den trump wenn er gesagt gesehen hätte hier,
der.
Der assange selbst sagt er hat's nicht von den russen und weil er es nicht von den russen hat kann ich ihn ja jetzt auch einen paten aussprechen ne also es passt wie arsch auf einmal.
Ist schon echt krass oder.
Also ja aber nicht überraschend also es so läuft's halt jetzt gerade ne also wenn die usa es nicht schaffen mit den nächsten wahlen diesen vogel zu entfernen.
Dann ist die politische kultur im arsch.
Dann ist nicht nur da also dann wird's so also dann werden die zwanziger nicht so golden wie ich das eigentlich hier in aussicht gestellt habe.
Du die werden ganz schön golden was meinst du was der trump noch alles vergolden wie.
Ach ja.
Schon die toilette vergoldet hast du aber deine goldenen zwanziger typ.
Oh gott jetzt muss ich trump und badezimmer denken.
Jetzt gibt's natürlich noch einen wichtigen satz in in dem new york times berichtet darüber glaube ich.
Wo ganz klar sagt der rombacher sagt er hat late assange willing corporate.
Trumps chef john kelly fördern von the white house also auch notar bene assange hat bereitschaft erklärt sich darauf einzulassen.
So sagt es zumindest dieser rohrbach der aber einen satz vorher auch schon darüber gelogen hat wenn er behauptet er hätte das einfach selber gemacht insofern schwierig schwierig.
Ja
Also da sind wir wieder in diesem in diesem diesem schwierigen gelände ja also das kann jetzt sein oder nicht sein.
Und wenn es so war kann es heißen er hat es einfach nur gemacht um.
Zu sehen was der nächste schritt ist also es sind alles spielchen die da getrieben werden so das heißt das.
Ja das tut.
Sagt jetzt erstmal gar nichts aus könnte auch sagen die tatsache dass er das jetzt hier von seinen anwälten vorliegen lässt.
Hätte auch irgendeine bedeutung kann sein kann nicht sein das ist alles taktieren und abspielen und absprache mit anwälten und meinungen und teilweise auch.
Kann schon sehr gut sein dass der dass der sv einfach gesagt hat pass mal auf dana da ist alles schön und gut was du dir sagst aber ich würde dann doch schon ganz gerne mal mit deinem vorgesetzten sprechen.
Um ja deutschland recht im zweifelsfall würdest du einem solchen,
solche typen aus der zweiten oder dritten reihe,
der da offenbar als unterhändler zu dir kommt ohne ohne mandat den würdest du im zweifelsfall sagen jo alles klar keep it coming aber ich möchte jetzt mal gerne mit leuten sprechen die entscheidungen haben und insofern.
Assange wäre blöd gewesen den rohrer bacher weg zu schicken ja das stimmt schon.
So dann gab es noch ein großes thema in der seit der letzten sendung oder eigentlich schon ich glaube zum zeitpunkt der letzten sendung war das schon thema als wir die veröffentlicht haben und zwar gibt es in der schweiz in zug.
Eine firma mit dem namen krypto ag die da seit jahrzehnten krypto lösungen verkauft und,
da gab es immer wieder gerüchte dass hinter dieser firma geheimdienste stünden die also nicht unbedingt vertrauenswürdige skript equipment verkaufen
und jetzt haben und andere
medien partnerschaften das gab's irgendwie so mehrere recherche verbände oder gruppen die sich da irgendwie gleichzeitig veröffentlicht haben die ein zweihundertachtzig seitiges geheimdienst in die hände bekommen haben,
das belegt dass die krypto a g,
manipulierte verschlüsselung geräte verkauft hat also die haben je nachdem wer da gekauft hat.
Entweder version ihres chiffre geräte oder version verkauft und die version b war eben.
Und das haben die gemacht bis mindestens zwanzig achtzehn so jetzt stellt sich die frage warum haben sie das gemacht ja weil dieser laden neunzehnhundertsiebzig,
vom,
n und der zu gleichen teilen über eine stiftung in lichtenstein gekauft wurde also der bnd und die haben neunzehnhundertsiebzig die krypto a g mit sitz in zug gekauft.
Und die hatte kunden ich glaube in einhundert oder einhundertzehn ländern und die verschlüsselung,
die sicher war wurde nur ein relativ wenige länder verkauft während alle anderen,
die kaputten geräte bekommen haben die dann eben von bmw und abgehört werden konnten,
beispiel länder die die geliefert haben saudi-arabien argentinien iran und die haben natürlich alle dort gekauft weil diese schweizer firma als eben lange am markt und neutral galt was während des kalten krieges.
Des nahostkonflikt eben natürlich relativ relevant ist,
die offenbar haben wir dann eben der bnd und das ding einfach gekauft und gesagt alles klar lass mal alle hier die schöne schweizer krypto kaufen und wir bauen eine schöne backdoor ein.
So das ist aber nicht unbedingt neu weil da stand auch schon vorher in der wikipedia neu scheint zu sein dass sie das jetzt belegt haben so krasse geschichte,
aber würde ich sagen fällt alles unter spirs bye,
interessant finde ich eigentlich nur eine reaktion darauf und zwar die veröffentlichung von wow,
am dreizehnten februar security notiz statement und media reports konzerne dropping bei control crypto.
Following reports beide guardian in washington post erbaut dropping carried control crypto und global communications equipment.
Kontakte investigation of partnerships can confirm the way no business die links,
crypto security crypto international ende der pressemitteilung.
Und das während die ganze welt darüber debattiert das überhaupt irgendwelche irgendwelche backdoors in seinen produkten hätte
veröffentlichen die woraus kommt das seit fünfzig jahren aus der mitte aus sitz in schweiz von irgendeiner krypto ag in hundertzehn ländern dieser erde
crypto verkauft wird er sagt du einfach nur in zwei sätzen haben wir nix mit zu tun das ist doch echt.
Es ist interessant weil in der ganzen debatte um war
und diesem argument mit oh gott die chinesen wollen uns abhören immer wieder so impliziert wird na ja das wäre jetzt sozusagen eine eine gefährdung aber am ende kann man das eben auch genauso gut sehen als also erstens wollen wir
das equipment verkaufen und zwar wollen wir das vor allem deshalb tun damit wir eben unsere abhören mechanismen in die welt kriegen können und da sind also die usa,
nicht vertrauenswürdige einzustufen als alle anderen und deswegen sollte man eben auch generell bei technologie immer allen,
grundsätzlich erstmal das gebotene misstrauen entgegenbringen und sich darlegen lassen nachvollziehbarer weise dass hier kein böser intendant
ist das einfach an irgendeinem land oder einer firma festzumachen ist halt einfach unsinn weil im prinzip können ja alle unterwandert werden.
Übrigens er hat sich hier der us-botschafter zu deutschland der grenell.
Letztens in dieser angelegenheit richtig schön verwittert.
Und zwar twitterte er donald trump hat mich gerade aus der airforce one angerufen und angewiesen klarzumachen dass jede nation die sich für einen nicht vertrauenswürdigen anbieter entscheidet,
und jetzt kommt's achtung unsere fähigkeit gefährdet informationen.
Und erkenntnisse auf höchstem niveau weiterzugeben.
So was sagt der da wirklich wenn ihr von huawei kauft dann.
Gefährdet ihr unsere möglichkeiten informationen weiterzugeben was streng genommen bedeuten könnte dass sie tatsächlich keine backdoor zu haben.
Dann ihren geheimdienst ring tauscht nicht mehr machen können.
Deswegen haben die schiss und deswegen sind die da auch so hinterher und deswegen ist das halt auch in diesem fall eis verbund so ein heißes thema.
Das könnte sein.
Es würde zu trumps intelligenz passen jemanden der sich so verplappert möglichst schnell als botschafter zu deutschland abzusetzen.
Und direkt zum geheimdienst koordinator zu machen denn die gute nachricht tim ist wir sind in grenell los der wird geheimdienst koordinator in den usa.
Die ist klar dass es nur so lange eine gute nachricht bis er den neuen botschafter benannt hat weil das auf den grenell jemand folgt mit dem ihr sehr viel glücklicher sind kannst du glaube ich komplett vergessen.
Das ist das erste und was glaube ich genauso scheiße ist das dass der dein geheimnis koordinator ist wobei ich meine alle leute die unter trump irgendwelche,
plätze besetzt haben haben die schon aus guten gründen besetzt aber ja der green day.
Ich kenne leute die halten sogar große stücke auf ihn aber ich kenne ihn ehrlich gesagt nicht von daher kann ich das nicht beurteilen.
Also das ich glaube die person kenne ich auch und ich muss sagen da halte ich wenig von weil wenn ich mir sein wirken anschaue was er von sich gibt,
wie er sich äußert wie er politisch wirkt in deutschland kann man sehr froh sein wenn der zurück über den großen teich fliegt und von mir aus der geheimdienst koordinator wird aber ein,
ein brauchbares ansprechpartner in einer botschaft war das glaube ich nicht,
wenn gleich er sicherlich seinen präsidenten in aller ihm gebührenden würde hier vertreten hat in diesem land den punkt muss man den gonell auf jeden fall.
Naja schauen wir mal was er als nächstes kommt so was haben wir denn noch ah ich hatte noch.
Ich will jetzt mal nicht die gute nachricht nennen aber ich dachte mal vielleicht so etwas was um so ein bisschen up lifting ist vielleicht so könnte könnte hier vielleicht noch ganz gut reinpassen hast du schon mal was von dem musical gehört.
Das ist so das könnt ihr euch einfach mal anschauen ich weiß nicht ob das die welt revolutionieren wird aber ich fand die idee einfach ganz interessant.
Und zwar folgendes da gibt's einen menschen der heißt damian real.
Der selber sich sowohl für musik interessiert programmieren kann aber ganz nebenbei vor allem rechtsanwalt ist.
Und der hat sich dann noch mit einem anderen programmierer und musiker namens nur rubin zusammengetan und wir haben mal eine interessante idee konsequent durchgespielt.
Und zwar geht es hier um copyright und zwar konkret um copyright von musik oder copyright von melodien und wir haben ja hier auch oft.
Schon so fälle behandelt wo es dann eben streit gibt und hier und er hat ja hier geklont und kopiert und das ist ja irgendwie meine idee und so weiter und da ganze
mit den entsprechenden tick down gesetzes maßnahmen die dann in den jahren gefolgt sind bis hin zu im jüngsten
copyright verschärfung maßnahmen etcetera p und dem problem dass eben copyright gerade im im kreativen bereich halt mit gilt dann nochmal neunzig jahre nach dem tod des letzten gestorbenen,
mit autoren gilt das ist einfach alles ein totaler wahnsinn ist.
Jetzt hat er sich das irgendwie mal angeschaut und hat gesagt so okay gut wie ist denn das definiert also ich kann,
quasi mein copyright auf ein lied in dem moment klemmen,
wo ich das ganze ich weiß nicht so ganz genau wie die technische formulierung oder die rechtliche formulierung ist aber wenn ich das sozusagen niederschreibe.
Und dabei reicht es eben heutzutage auch schon aus dass sozusagen auf ein gerät niederzuschreiben also ich das auch beim computer speichere,
das vorliegen habe dann ist damit sozusagen die sache erfunden die melodie ist geschaffen das werk ist erzeugt und dann habe ich da eben ein anspruch
auf urheberrecht drauf und kann dann auch später leute verklagen selbst wenn die behaupten
niemals kenntnis gehabt zu haben davon dass ich das eben vorher schon mal gemacht habe wenn ich das nur beweisen kann dass ich das vorher hatte
dann kann ich halt alle in grund und boden verklagen wenn sie später ist auch nur wagen eine melodie zu veröffentlichen die eben die meine sei.
Und dann sind sie immer so hingegangen und sagt so naja okay wie viele melodien gibt's eigentlich weil die sache ist ja dann,
relativ endlich man hat so ein noten system und das entspannt sich über so ein paar oktaven,
und dann haben sie mal geschaut so okay was sind denn eigentlich so schützenswerte melodien
wie wenig noten haben denn ausgereicht um eine melodie dann auch tatsächlich dem copyright zu unterstellen und nach einigen hin und her und es gibt einen schönen tag noch ein paar andere berichte die ich verlinkt habe
wo sie das alles mal dargelegt haben was da sozusagen ihre schlussfolgerung waren sind sie hergegangen und haben ein paar ein programm geschrieben,
was einfach alle permutation aller denkbaren musiken erzeugt in midi und ist auf eine festplatte speichert.
Und sie meinen halt dass jetzt sozusagen music,
also jede melodie die künftig in irgendeiner form von irgendjemand nochmal erdacht und aufgeschrieben werden kann bereits aufgeschrieben haben und stellen das unter publik domain und sagen könnt ihr benutzen.
Sehr schön.
Geile idee ob das in irgendeiner form vor gericht einen bestand haben wird
das werden wir jetzt nochmal sehen aber dazu hilft es auf jeden fall davon überhaupt erstmal kenntnis zu haben und ich bin da
drüber gestolpert ihr findet die ganze musik zum runterladen unter all the music dort info also sie haben sich dann letzten endes auf maximal zwölf noten
innerhalb einer oktave in irgendwie es wird alles detailliert beschrieben in dem video
haben sich darauf beschränkt und das ist sozusagen abrufbar und damit kann man halt quasi belegen dass eine bestimmte melodie soll hätte sie denn mal verwenden wollt vermutlich schon mal niedergeschrieben wurde und damit liegt das copyright halt bei denen und die verzichten eben darauf.
Hübsch oder.
Sehr schön ja wollen wir noch ein paar termine machen.
Auf jeden fall weil ausnahmsweise gibt's ja jetzt auch mal wieder ein paar termine.
Es geht los mit dem geburtstag des chaos computer clubs freiburg der findet statt am sechsten märz zweitausendzwanzig da ist es nämlich dann zehn jahre her,
dass der c freiburg gegründet wurde die öffnen,
deshalb am sechsten dritten ab fünfzehn uhr die türen und werden die erst wieder am sonntagabend den achten dritten schließen der zwischen wird gekocht getrunken gefeiert.
Und dann für freunde eines gemütlichen autor hacker camps gibt es ein angebot am,
ende juli anfang august dieses jahres in luxemburg für überschaubare teilnehmerzahlen hundertfünfzig leute werden hier erwartet das green,
findet glaube ich das zweite oder die glaube ich schon das dritte oder vierte mal statt unter dem schönen,
motto im sinne von internet of trees findet das ganze in dude lounge auf einem campingplatz über den,
auf dem berg ist der berg erhebung über den dächern der stadt statt und sieht ganz hübsch aus habe ich mir mal auf google.
Der dfb ist jetzt eröffnet und der ticketverkauf startet auch schon am neunundzwanzigsten zwölften.
Einundzwanzigsten zweiten.
Zweiten stimmt ich bin immer noch im falschen jahr verhaftet ja.
Ja und dann haben wir noch was.
In siegen wird es eine chaos flugs geben die erste chaos veranstaltung von chaos siegen für szene kulturschaffende und künstlerinnen,
ende april nämlich vom freitag den vierundzwanzigsten bis sonntag den sechsundzwanzigsten april und zwar in wer hätte das gedacht achtung siegen,
es gibt kostenlose tickets aber um ordentlich zu planen hätten sie gerne eine anmeldung sodass man sich irgendwie,
dass dass man sich darauf vorbereiten kann wer so kommen wird.
Und wird zwischen dem bruchweg theater als atelierhaus edition neunzehn kaffee planlos museum für gegenwartskunst und campus untere schloss.
Ausgerichtet werden tickets und merch gibts unter chaos flugs de.
Achso und natürlich gibt es auch ein sehr viel unter programmpunkt chaos flux punkt de.
Gut damit sind wir am ende der sendung du hast noch ein paar danksagungen.
Ja und zwar würde ich gerne danken christian heiko und einer unbekannten person.
Das denkmal für den unbekannten spender und förderer das muss noch errichtet.
Na ja das ist nur um das zu,
das ist ja immer so der hinweis dass eventuell wenn jetzt hier eine person ihren namen erwartet hätte dass ich den eben nicht erfahren habe und wenn sie daran etwas ändern möchte dann muss sie eventuell sich kurz mal an mich wenden.
Okay alle anderen sind dann hier in meinem ich habe hier so ein kleines denkmal für den unbekannten spender aber heutzutage der ganze daten die ganzen daten abfragen die man machen kann er bleibt ja keiner mehr unbekannt.
Vor allem wenn ihr wenn ihr demnächst beleidigende spenden kommen dann melden wir direkt ans bkk.
Ach so aber sowas von.
Passwort da können wir nichts.
Nur noch daten übermittlung daten übermittlung so leute das war's bis nächste woche oder so.
Vielen herzlichen dank und bis dahin tschau tschau.
Ich habe einen grünen partner mit einem goldenen nagler drauf dies bedingt dass ich mir auf die haare rauf jetzt mal ohne spaß er gab nicht zu hause verboten ich langsam autofahrer
niemals all das gerede von europäischem zusammenschluss war ich zur grenze mit dem zug oder einen bus frag ich mich warum ich der einzige bin der sich aus weisen muss identität zu beweisen muss
ist das so ungewöhnlich weil ein afrodeutsche seine sprache spricht und ich glaube dass es dem gesicht das booking sind die ideen im system,
deutscher muss so richtig deutsch aussehen blaue augen keine gefahr gab's da nicht schon mal so was willst du mal später zurück in deine heimat,
nach heidelberg wo ich ein heim hab nein du weißt was ich meine komm lass das sein ich kenne diese frage bei dem ich klein bin in diesem land vor zwei jahrzehnten geboren doch frage ich mich manchmal was hab ich hier verloren.
Ignorant ist geschwätzt ohne ende dumme sprüche die man bereits alle kennt ihr wisst am ricardo oder kommst,
ein kommentar über meiner was ist daran so sonderbar ach du bist deutscher komm erzähl keinen scheiß du willst ja beweis hier ist mein ausweis gestatten sie mein name ist frederik.
Nach paris den andere gar nicht verlassen doch sie müssen fliehen feindlichkeit komplett minderwertigkeit ich will schockierend provozieren meine brüder und schwestern wie dein neuer motivieren ich habe schon einen plan,
und wenn es drauf ankommt kämpfe ich auch im auge zahn und zahn ich hoffe die radiosender lassen diese platte spielen denn ich bin kein einzelfall sommer einer von vielen nicht anerkannt fremd im eigenen land keine ausländer und doch ein fremder,
von einer überschnittenen aufnahmekapazität es wird einem erklärt dann wird einem vertreter in einer betrogen gerät somit denkt der bürger der vorurteile pflegt dass wir ihn eine große gefahr entsteht er sie verliert entgegen,
seine deutsche lebensqualität leider kommt zahlt denn jemand der fragt wie es um nicht schlecht bezahlte unbeliebte arbeit steht kaum ein eis da überlegt auf das wissen mehr.
Warum ist nichts am land so gut geht dass der gastarbeiter seit den siebzigern unentwegt,
zum wirtschafts aufbau der sich blühende bewegt mit kurzen beitrag und noch bei tracks mit einer schwachen position in der gesellschaft blick in krisenzeit in oldenburg und das eigentliche problem dass man übergeht wird einfach unauffällig unter den teppich gefickt,
nicht anerkannt fremd im eigenen land keine ausländer und doch ein fremder.
Danach wenn ich in die falsche straße laufen komm den raum aus maul
gut dass ich hier mal schnell war beim hundert meter lauf gewalt in gestalt deiner faustschläger bald oder einem blitz in der metern aber auch für die knallt viele werden behaupten wir würden übertreiben doch seit zwanzig jahren leben wir hier sind es leicht zu schweigen entstehen polizei steht daneben ein deutscher,
um sein leben in der fernsehsendung die wiedervereinigung anfangs habe ich mich gefreut habe ich bereut dennoch nicht seit ich denken kann was so schlimm wie heute,
politiker köpfe reden viel doch bleiben kalt und kühl alles passt genau in die kalkül man zeigt sich besorgt begibt sich vor ort nimmst dein kind auf den schoß für's nette schon gesorgt mit jedem kamera blitz ein neuer sitz im bundestag da lässt man ein neues gesetz,
klar asylbewerber müssen raus und keiner macht den verschluss den garaus sie sie ist nicht meine welt in der farbe und herkunft zählt der waren von überfremdung politisch und werte erhält,
der handschuh bestellt sich selbst für den fachmann,
bin erzogen worden die dinge anders zu sehen hinter fassaden blicken zusammenhänge verstehen mit respekt und direkt zu jedem menschen stehen ethische werte die über nationale grenzen gehen ich habe den grünen park mit einem goldenen adler drauf.
Mich fremd hier.